'on ne veut
[Musique]
les bouquinistes de paris sont connus
dans le monde entier
c'est pourtant et métiers un beau métier
qui disparaît la construction de la voie
express rive gauche risque d'être pour
eux un arrêt de mort
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui vous inquiète le plus dans
ces travaux de la voirie plonge à nous
sommes d'autant plus inquiet que nous
n'avons aucun droit théoriquement sur
notre emplacement que l'administration
que nous nous faire partir dans les 48
heures que nous le devrons évidemment
partir si les travaux se font ici et que
nous avons toujours et que nous ne
savons pas encore si nous serons mieux
ou et on se demande surtout qu'on a déjà
déménagé une veine case and any et c'est
pas drôle vous savez on va dans un autre
cas
on fait la moitié moins de temps de
travail et
les boîtes ont lésé skate parce que faut
y aller l'abord pu revenir ça paie deux
fois déménagé parce que ce métier qui
rentable que le métier a certainement
été rentable puisqu'il ya des
bouquinistes depuis plus de 100 ans mais
devient effectivement de moins en moins
rentable nous sommes tous obligés
d'alexey quelque chose d'autre à la
vente du livre ne seraient ce des
gravures des cartes postales des timbres
de la monette et arabe n'est plus le
métier que c'était voilà quelques temps
on n'est ce pas en tout plus de bons
bouquins ya plus des policiers il ya
plus que des gravures des
les cartes postales de tous les livres à
bon marché puisque le public a évolué
oui aussi
d'abord la télé nous a tués et puis les
trois quarts des jeunes ménages vivre au
dessus de leurs moyens là
défense mbia les livres mais ils disent
que nous avons vendu beaucoup de livres
il veut relier pour faire des garnitures
à mes gars n'ont jamais lu ses livres là
à côté de ça c'est en général le pauvre
qui d'ici et là c'est un lieu à 3 francs
il est content de lui le lit mais les
pros livres précédents des radiants sont
pas du tout les bons souvenirs que vous
avez comme cookies liste mais les bons
souvenirs on savait j'ai toujours des
bons souvenirs
est-ce qu'on n'est pas arrivé d'avoir
des manuscrits et de documents
particulièrement rare
oui une fois dans un lot j'ai acheté
alcool d'apollinaire édition originale
avec un dessin de picasso qui vaut 250
milles maintenant que j'ai gardées page
family office
métier de bouquinistes c'est d'abord
aimer les livres ce que j'ai fait
j'étais amateur avant des bouquinistes
suis comme livreur qui devient marchand
demain et puis on aime la clientèle
parce qu'à un collectionneur vous
apporter quelque chose
est-ce qu'on sent bien imaginer paris 5e
finissent au nom n'en produit pas du
tout non non non je vois l'avenir sont
meilleurs a toujours des bouquinistes
il faut le souhaiter non seulement pour
les bouquinistes mais surtout pour paris
[Musique]